etwn's Owen Jensen asked cringe
Jean-Pierre what she thinks about guys
competing in women's sports
did the president say to parents out
there who have daughters say from high
school for example were worried that
their daughter may have to compete
against a male or a person born male and
then there could be directly in
physically athletic competition and
worry about their daughter's safety so
look uh I'm what you're alluding to is
basically saying that transgender kids
are dangerous it sounds like that's what
you're saying well you're saying you
should you're saying that their safety
is that isn't is at risk yeah but you're
you're laying out a broad kind of broad
example or explanation of what could
potentially happen a broad a broad
example explained that is dangerous that
is a dangerous thing to say that
essentially transgender kids were
talking about are dangerous and so
that's something that I have to call out
and that is that is that is that is
irresponsible I had just laid out how
complicated this issue is I just laid
out why it's complicated and so anything
that you have any additional questions I
refer to the Department of Education I'm
going to move on I know there are other
people okay
no I mean you could read your question
in a transcript once you get it go ahead
God she's she's
hold on I want you all to think about
what she is I'm going to pause for five
seconds here I'm gonna think about a
couple things couple Choice words for
her I already said tits so we're screwed
today anyway I could probably just go
ahead and do it you hear five seconds
think of a couple adjectives for her
well I had a good one it wasn't the one
you're thinking but it was a good one
um
look trans kids a boy who pretends he's
a girl and then wrestles a 15 year old
girl to the ground and crushes her and
breaks her skull this is a problem
Leah Thomas who is a dude with a penis
which he uses as a propeller to beat
girls in swimming is a problem the trans
movement is radically anti-girl it is
radically anti-gay because most of the
boys that are transitioning are probably
just gay boys and most of the girls who
are transitioning are probably just gay
girls and some of them are neither of
those
these people are never going to stop
they ha even the way that the that was
CBS News the headline that you saw on
the bottom and it was about anti-trans
legislation again there is no anti-trans
legislation there is legislation to stop
mutilating children and I as I said
yesterday I'm fairly certain if there
was a massive mainstream Movement by
white Christians to generally to
mutilate the genitals of children I'm
fairly certain all these people would be
against it
you got it it's just absolutely
ridiculous I'm not kidding I I may throw
on a wig and a dress little lipstick
we've got some around here somewhere and
I'm going to join the WNBA I am 40 I'm
going to be 47 in 10 days okay I am will
be a 47 year old dude with a torn ACL in
my left knee I wear three braces I put
the ace bandage I got a sleeve and the
the metal thing and I'm gonna get out
there and I'm gonna be the the NBA the
WNBA MVP
I know I could score a double digits for
sure in a WNBA game I can still shoot I
got a finger roll
you know it's all there finger all
lesbians
[Music]